back in 2015 i hated the idea of doing
any sort of stuff that involved g-forces
it absolutely terrified me uh you can
see that uh the very first time that i
did a loop in a glider oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy don't freak out
don't freak out don't freak out i was
freaked out the whole time but since
then i've done so much stuff in in so
many wonderful things that i've learned
to love it
and i want to do it again so i figured
i'd invite a friend
hello hello that was natural wasn't it
i was waiting poised just off camera to
walk perfectly on cue in yep no it's a
this is the first video that we're
filming for this channel we have no idea
not like we've got a camera up we've got
a producer i have no idea what's going
to happen well neither do i i got a text
from you a while back and you said um
how do you feel about aerobatics yes and
i had no idea what you meant i didn't
know you were inviting me to do a video
i just thought you were asking my
opinion so i said yeah sounds fun and
then you said okay great we'll do a
video and i also decided not to google
what aerobatics is because i imagine
whatever you have planned for today it's
bound to have safety harnesses coming
out of my ear holes and you know how
dangerous could it be
first things first i'm not flying you uh
this is the british aerobatic academy
so these are the pilots who teach pilots
to do aerobatics by which you mean we
are in arguably the safest possible
place we could be for being flown in a
tiny plane i'm not qualified to fly this
i'm frankly not qualified to go near it
without someone else around so
also here standing awkwardly out of the
camera shot
introduce yourself please i'm joe and
welcome to british air base academy the
two planes are going to be flying today
is both extras uh this is the extra 300
and out there we've got an extra 200.
the only difference is this one is
slightly bigger and
the thing in the front that pulls you
along
has got 100 more horsepower right okay
the guy in charge of our safety cord the
thing in the front that pulls you along
they both are very capable and can do
every aerobatic maneuver that you would
ever
dream about and probably not dream about
i'm nervously looking around for one of
those signs that says x number of days
without an accident
jump and show you guys around yes please
see the plane my wife has insisted that
i text her the minute we land because
she's really worried i feel like she's
more worried than you at this point it
might rise either that i have perfect
confidence in joe and in the system
or i'm just blocking it out of my mind
so this is what you're going to be
sitting in
as you can see there's not much room
yeah you guys will be in the front
okay instructor will be in the back the
main thing for you guys in the front
is probably that little paper thing
there
okay hang on
is it a six bag it's a sick bag ah okay
good yes
it's got a five point harness
so um any negative or positive g you
shouldn't move out of your seat
shouldn't be in the keyword what happens
if we get bored and want to leave
well we don't have a parachute so
um
if you want to leave
you're not going to go home to your wife
[Laughter]
that was that was more bleak than i
thought it was going to be
am i imagining that this thing is
literally held together with duct tape
yes
that is not a critical part of the
airplane
that is more just for people in
competitions
and
to get the plane going dead straight up
i like this casual mention yeah what are
you flying vertically up that's uh he's
telling us like we've got to do the
controls
[Laughter]
you have
really yes you'll get a chance to do it
oh i didn't know that i didn't know that
i thought i thought i was just going to
be sat in the front and enjoying the
view but you know i've got a job to do
they'll give you they'll give you a go
yeah oh wow could i endanger us
uh no
why'd you ask me
so that i can hear the reassuring no of
course not we obviously don't let people
do that
the tone of your voice was like oh can i
like that
can i kill us both please no uh
obviously i have an instructor in the
back so they'll be talking through i was
already like really excited and i'm
really really really excited i'm going
to actually kind of fly a plane and not
injure us there we go that's important
that's your main bit obviously coming
here it's like it's fine i've done this
before jay will be nervous and now it's
it's kind of the other way just with
i'm excited i feel like a boy in an
airplane hangar
this still makes me feel like a big
strong man you know driving those clips
of jeff capes like pulling on a pulling
a plate all by himself that's a
reference i've known in a while
right
should we leave it here then
so the plan is that we're gonna depart
from here we're gonna experience a
little bit of formation flying and how
it is flying formation tommy have some
experience with that a little more yeah
so it's gonna be a bit of a
a new thing for jay i have no experience
with this at all see tom's got the
advantage here because you've done this
before i don't think i invited you
do you you already know what your limits
are and you know like what you like and
don't like in a plane i have no idea if
i'm going to love it and do you know 17
more loops to loop than you do
or if i'm going to feel sick after two
seconds see i i think i'm okay with this
because i've done i've done loops and
rolls i've done a stall turn and i've
done a break
but i've not gone beyond that and i
don't know what my limit is so it's
quite possible that we're going to get
up there and we're going to get to that
it's no uh that's as far as i can go and
you're going to blast past me i have no
idea so yeah we'll go on the trip of
pursuing your limits so try to find what
they are
like we might try multiple rows or loops
combined with rows or
some spinning inverted spinning or
whatever you prefer should i be filling
out some kind of will before i go up
i hope you guys will enjoy it
any questions yeah is it at all possible
for me to endanger us
pardon me
can you phrase that differently jay that
sounds like you're asking permission
can i
yep
so i'm standing on the cushions
send another question so that's on the
questions just here yep
i said stand on the cushions and i
didn't stand on the cushions never felt
safer in my life
i do wonder how jay's feeling because
he's he's had this kind of i'm fine i'm
all calm nothing can go wrong demeanor
and i wonder how he's feeling right now
hey tom we can communicate from plane to
plane like this
how are you feeling
i'm still feeling kind of numb i'm sort
of waiting for the nurse to set in i
reckon it'll happen as soon as we take
off probably
brilliant what we need now is just some
dramatic soaring music
happen
[Music]
oh
there's a part of me that just wants it
to carry on like this where it's all
nice and smooth
but that's not why we're here
[Music]
no you know what's really cool
that's not what this guy normally is
how many
yes you did
feel
[Music]
okay
um
[Music]
really
ah
okay
yes
give me okay seconds
okay
three two one
backwards
[Music]
okay
my brain is saying this is great this is
amazing and my stomach is saying here
you go
so your stomach can't take it and my
blood pressure can't take it
between us we're a competent aerobatic
pilot
thank you by the way this feels like a
good opportunity to look over to your
plane and say thank you so much for
inviting me along for this opportunity
it's been a pleasure thank you so much
to everyone at the british aerobatic
academy to our pilot to the team on the
ground uh that's the new channel i hope
you like it
[Music]
you